This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you're a baseball fan, you might remember the 1997 playoffs. That's when pitcher Levant Hernandez was unstoppable. Can Levant Hernandez get out of it? Yes he can. Hernandez was a rookie for the Florida Marlins, and his masterpiece was Game 5 of the National League Championship Series against Atlanta.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你是个棒球迷，你可能还记得1997年的季后赛。当时投手利万·埃尔南德斯势不可挡。利万·埃尔南德斯能化解危机吗？是的，他可以。埃尔南德斯当时是佛罗里达马林鱼队的一名新秀，而他的巅峰之作是国家联盟冠军赛对阵亚特兰大队的第五场比赛。
That's producer Chris Barouba. Levant Hernandez struck out 15 batters that game, which for context is so many batters. It was an incredible night, but a lot of his strikes, they weren't actually strikes. Hernandez was pretty consistently missing the zone This pitch is I would say a foot two feet outside of the strike zone Not close called a strike. That's baseball analyst Katie Nolan. She vividly remembers that game because it really was not good.
那是制作人克里斯·巴鲁巴。利万·埃尔南德斯在那场比赛中三振了15名打者，说实话，这个三振数非常惊人。那是一个不可思议的夜晚，但他投的好球中，有很多其实并不是真正的好球。埃尔南德斯相当稳定地偏离了好球区。这个球，我想说，在好球区外一到两英尺。离得这么远却被判了ストライク（好球）。那是棒球分析师凯蒂·诺兰。她对那场比赛记忆犹新，因为那实在有点离谱。
I mean, okay, second pitch, way outside called a strike. A Grigis. A Grigis. Cady and I rewatch video from that game with, let's call it a perverse fascination. Almost none of the batters actually swung at his pitches. You see Hernandez just winding up and throwing ball after ball like a foot outside the strike zone. And then, inexplicably, the umpire Eric Greg, he just kept making the hand signal for a strike.
我是说，好吧，第二球，离得十万八千里远却被判了好球。太离谱了。太离谱了。凯蒂和我带着一种可以说是反常的痴迷重新观看了那场比赛的录像。几乎没有打者对他的球挥棒。你可以看到埃尔南德斯只是在挥臂，一球又一球地投出远在好球区外一英尺的球。然后，莫名其妙地，裁判埃里克·格雷格就一直做出好球的手势。
It was so bad. It was probably the worst um, um, um, um, I've, I can remember the outside of this strike zone, um, it just didn't end. It was like a never ending strike zone. In case you don't know anything about baseball, in the major leagues, there are four umpires on the field, one behind each base and one behind home plate. The home plate umpire has the most important job, which is calling balls and strikes. A strike is basically any hitable pitch, something over the plate, between the batter's chest and his knees, and a ball is everything else. I remember watching games as a kid, and whenever an umpire blew it, I would say, I could
这太糟糕了。这可能是我能记住的最糟糕的、最糟糕的……好球区外侧的判罚，而且这简直没完没了。就像是一个永无止境的好球区。如果你对棒球一无所知，在职业棒球大联盟中，场上有四名裁判，每个垒包后面各一个，还有一个在本垒板后面。本垒板裁判的任务最重要，那就是判定好球和坏球。好球基本上是任何可以击中的球，也就是在好球板上方、打者胸部到膝盖之间的球，而坏球则是其他所有的球。我记得小时候看比赛，每当裁判作出糟糕的判罚时，我会说：“我能”
do better than that. And so I tried. I was a little league and high school umpire from the age of 14 until my early 20s, and I think I could have gone pro if it weren't for my poor eyesight my aversion to getting yelled at and the time I was hitting the throat by baseball. My point is even in the little leagues getting calls right is a lot harder than it looks. And at the pro level the baseball is moving at like 95 miles an hour. It's kind of incredible that on average umpires get it right about 94 to 97% of the time on strike calls.
做得比他更好。于是我尝试了。从14岁到20出头，我曾担任过少年联盟和高中的裁判，我想如果不是因为我视力不好、讨厌被人嘘，以及曾被棒球击中喉咙的经历，我本来可以成为职业裁判的。我想说的是，即使是在少年联盟，把判罚做对也比看起来要难得多。而在职业水平上，棒球的飞行速度大约是每小时95英里。平均而言，裁判在好球判罚上有大约94%到97%的时间能做出正确判断，这其实相当不可思议。
And umpires are getting better. The worst umpire today would have been upper tier in 1997. But the crazy high speed to the baseball means, sometimes umpires are going to get it wrong. It just feels to me like it's asking a lot of the umpire to be able to recognize if it nifty inside of the strike zone on its way over the plate or if it didn't. And I know we all make fun of the egregious calls, but I feel like some of them, you're not standing back there, you're not having to do it entirely with your eye, it's got to
而且裁判们还在不断进步。如今最差的裁判放在1997年也能达到高水平。但棒球惊人的高速意味着，裁判有时难免会判错。在我看来，要求裁判在棒球飞过本垒板的途中去分辨它是否擦到了好球区的内边缘，这实在是强人所难。我知道我们都在调侃那些离谱的判罚，但我觉得其中有些球，你没有站在那个位置，你不能完全凭肉眼去完成，那一定
be really difficult. One study from 2018 found that umpmpires blow about 14 calls every game. That's 34,000 bad calls every year, and it makes a difference, like in the Levant Hernandez game. The Florida Marlins came out on top, and a few weeks later, they won the World Series. These calls can make all the difference between a win and a loss, a championship, and sitting at home for six months, just wondering what could have been if it only made the right call.
非常困难。2018年的一项研究发现，裁判每场比赛大约会做出14次错误的判罚。这意味着每年有34,000次误判，而且这确实会产生影响，比如在利万·埃尔南德斯的比赛中。佛罗里达马林鱼队最终获胜，几周后，他们赢得了世界大赛。这些判罚足以决定一场比赛的胜负、一个总冠军，以及让你在家里坐上六个月，脑子里只想着：要是当时判对了就好了。
Given the human fallibility of umpires, Major League Baseball has been considering something drastic, something that would take us up to 100% accuracy. They have a plan to replace human umpires with robots. Like any scenario where a human being is being replaced by a robot, there is the question of whether robots can do a better, more accurate job. And in baseball, a sport that is legendary for its quirks and its general human imperfection, there's another trickier question. Is more accurate what we actually want? The idea of replacing an umpire with a machine isn't new. In the 1950s, the Brooklyn Dodgers tested a robot umpire designed by General Electric.
鉴于裁判作为人类难免会犯错，美国职业棒球大联盟一直在考虑采取某种激进的举措，一种能将准确率提升到100%的方法。他们计划用机器人取代人类裁判。就像任何人类被机器人取代的场景一样，这里也存在一个问题：机器人能否做得更好、更准确？而在棒球这项以古怪脾性和人类普遍的不完美而闻名的运动中，还有另一个更棘手的问题：更高的准确率真的是我们想要的吗？用机器取代裁判的想法并不新鲜。在20世纪50年代，布鲁克林道奇队就测试过由通用电气设计的一个机器人裁判。
The GE umpire was a big machine, it kind of looked like a barbecue hooked up to a specially tricked out home plate. If the ball cast a shadow over the plate, the machine would light up a big red button, indicating a strike. The trouble is the machine didn't work very well. It made a lot of bad calls, and if it was a night game, the robot umpire just didn't work at all. In the 1950s, the technology just wasn't ready, and the robot umpire went nowhere. For years, the idea seemed like a non-starter. But a few years ago, the Commissioner of Major League Baseball, Rob Manfred, said he was considering robot umps for the big leagues.
GE的机器人裁判是一个大机器，看起来有点像一个连着特制本垒板的烧烤炉。如果球在本垒板上投下阴影，机器就会亮起一个代表好球的大红灯。问题是这个机器并不怎么好用。它做出了很多错误的判罚，而且如果是夜间比赛，机器人裁判根本无法工作。在20世纪50年代，技术根本还不成熟，机器人裁判最终无疾而终。多年来，这个想法似乎根本行不通。但几年前，美国职业棒球大联盟专员罗布·曼弗雷德表示，他正在考虑在大联盟中引入机器人裁判。
The robot umpires of the 21st century are a lot more sophisticated than a barbecue. But modern robot umpires, they aren't technically robots. That's what a lot of people picture is, like, you know, boop boop boop boop, kind of a metallic thing behind home plate. What it really is, it's this system. That's Zach Helfent. He's an editor and sports writer at The New Yorker. And today's version of the robot umpire
21世纪的机器人裁判比烧烤炉要复杂得多。但现代的机器人裁判从技术上讲并不是机器人。很多人脑海中浮现的画面是，你知道的，哔哔哔哔，本垒板后面立着个金属怪物。但它实际上的样子，其实是这样一套系统。那是扎克·赫尔芬特。他是《纽约客》的一名编辑和体育作家。而如今版本的机器人裁判
is actually a series of HD cameras. But for some reason the name Integrated Camera Baseball Tracking System has never caught on. So for this story, we're just going to keep calling them robots. I prefer Robo. I just think Robo sounds better. Baseball won't be the first sport to use Robo's two referee games. In tennis, there's a tracking system called Hawkeye
实际上是一系列高清摄像机。但出于某种原因，“集成摄像机棒球追踪系统”这个名字从来没有流行起来。所以在我们今天的节目里，我们还是管它们叫机器人。我更喜欢“Robo”（机甲裁判）。我只是觉得Robo听起来更酷。棒球不会是第一项在比赛中使用机器人裁判的运动。在网球中，有一个叫做“鹰眼”的追踪系统
that can pinpoint whether a ball is in or out of bounds. And it was good. Woo! What a shot. And in soccer, they use motion tracking cameras to help determine off sides and whether the ball has crossed the goal line. And the goal has been disallowed.
可以精准定位球是在界内还是界外。这球真漂亮。哇！好球。而在足球运动中，他们使用动作追踪摄像系统来帮助判定越位以及球是否越过了球门线。这个进球被判无效。
In fact, most major league baseball stadiums already have a sophisticated ball tracking system in place. Those were installed in the early 2000s for TV broadcasts to give fans a clear picture of what happened during every pitch. To track things like exit velocity off the bat, how fast the ball is moving off the bat, spin rate, it counts every single revolution of a baseball from when it leaves a pitcher's hand to when it gets
事实上，大多数美国职业棒球大联盟的球场都已经配备了先进的球体追踪系统。这些系统是在20世纪2000年代初安装的，用于电视转播，以便让球迷在每个投球过程中都能清晰地了解发生了什么。为了追踪诸如球棒击球初速度——也就是球离开球棒时的飞行速度——以及旋转率等数据，它会计算棒球从离开投手手掌到到达
to the plate. So, they have these very sophisticated missile tracking systems, essentially, in ball parks. By the way, he is not exaggerating. This is based on missile tracking technology. If you've watched a baseball game on TV, you've seen this tracking system in action. In Replays, broadcasters will show you charts and scatterplots to lay out where the ball landed inside the strike zone.
本垒板的每一次旋转。所以，基本上他们是在球场里安装了这些非常复杂的导弹追踪系统。顺便说一句，他并没有夸大其词。这是基于导弹追踪技术。如果你在电视上看过棒球比赛，你就见过这个追踪系统在运作。在回放中，转播商会向你展示图表和散点图，以标明球落在好球区的具体位置。
But the umpires that people actually making the calls don't have access to this information, only viewers do, which creates some awkward moments for fans. Wait, if we know that's a strike, why is he calling it a ball? It just doesn't make sense. Why doesn't he have the information I have? He should make the right call. But look, baseball is a pretty conservative sport. It's slow to embrace change.
但是真正做出判罚的裁判却无法获取这些信息，只有观众能看到，这就给球迷带来了一些尴尬的时刻。等等，如果我们知道那是好球，他为什么判成坏球？这根本说不通。为什么他没有我掌握的信息？他应该做出正确的判罚啊。但是听着，棒球是一项相当保守的运动。它对接受改变的反应很慢。
So for now, robot umpires are being tested on the minor leagues to work out some of the kinks and to help fans get used to the whole concept. Since 2019, robot ump technology has been working its way through the minor leagues, where it's called ABS for automatic balls and strikes. Last year, the ABS made its way to AAA, the highest level of minor league baseball. I wanted to see this robot umpire, okay, ABS system, in action. So I bought a ticket to watch some minor league baseball
所以目前，机器人裁判正在小联盟中进行测试，以解决一些技术问题，并帮助球迷适应整个概念。自2019年以来，机器人裁判技术一直在小联盟中逐步推广，在那里它被称为ABS，即自动好坏球系统（Automatic Balls and Strikes）。去年，ABS系统进入了小联盟的最高级别——3A级别（Triple-A）。我很想亲眼看看这个机器人裁判，也就是ABS系统，是如何运作的。于是我买了一张票去观看小联盟的棒球比赛
last summer in fabulous El Paso, Texas, where the hometown chihuahua were taking on the Albuquerque isotopes. But I got COVID, so I had to watch the game at home. The field and the isotopes in position, Riley Smith will start his last eight final warmup tosses before we get underway with tonight's game. Coming into the game, I was worried the baseball experience would feel totally different without
去年夏天在美妙的德克萨斯州埃尔帕索，家乡的奇瓦瓦狗队迎战阿尔伯克基同位素队。但我得了新冠，所以不得不窝在家里看比赛。场地上同位素队已经就位，里利·史密斯将开始他在今晚比赛开打前的最后八次热身投球。在观看比赛之前，我曾担心没有了裁判，棒球体验会感觉完全不同，
the umpires, because for me, they're essential to the fabric of the game. But actually, I didn't miss the human umpires, because they were still there. Fans here tonight's umpires, behind home plate, is Dylan Wilson, down the first baseline were still there. For those you worried about robots coming for human jobs, at least in this case, the humans are safe. Baseball still needs humans for lots of important jobs, like calling timeouts or cleaning home plate with those tiny adorable brooms. This robot umpire was actually a collaboration between the ABS system that made the call
因为对我来说，他们是比赛本质中不可或缺的一部分。但实际上，我并没有怀念人类裁判，因为他们依然在场上。今晚的球迷们，本垒板后面的裁判是迪伦·威尔逊，一垒边线附近的裁判也依然在。对于那些担心机器人会抢走人类工作的人来说，至少在这个案例中，人类的工作是安全的。棒球仍然需要人类来完成许多重要的工作，比如叫暂停，或者用那些小巧可爱的扫帚清理本垒板。这个机器人裁判实际上是做出判罚的ABS系统
and the human umpire who set it out loud. I listened with the earpiece along to a minor league game and it's more or less instantaneous. The ball hits the glove, you kind of hear the smack of the ball and the glove, and a split second later, you hear strike or ball. And it's funny, the strike is very peppy. And you know, it sounds very encouraging
与大声喊出判罚的人类裁判共同协作的产物。我戴着耳机收听了一场小联盟的比赛，这个过程几乎是即时的。球击中手套，你能听到手套接球时的啪的一声，紧接着不到一秒钟，你就会听到“好球”或“坏球”。很有趣的是，好球的声音非常欢快。你知道的，听起来非常鼓舞人心
and the ball is ball kind of disappointed. It's a man's voice just saying ball of strike. Ball, strike, ball, strike. That's Fred DeJesus. He was actually the first umpire to use the ABS system in 2019. Fun fact, his earpiece is now part of the collection at the baseball Hall of Fame. I obviously couldn't get there as a player, so I made my earpiece made. My joke is six Puerto Ricans have made it and one Puerto Ricans earpiece has made it. Fred says at first, he was wary about the ABS, but he came around pretty quickly. You know, one in Rome, you do what the Romans want.
而坏球的声音则显得有点失望。那是一个男人的声音，只是在说好球或坏球。好球，坏球，好球，坏球。那是弗雷德·德赫苏斯。他实际上是2019年第一位使用ABS系统的裁判。趣事：他的耳机现在是棒球名人堂藏品的一部分。我显然无法以球员身份进名人堂，所以我让我的耳机进了。我的笑话是：有六个波多黎各人进了名人堂，还有一个波多黎各人的耳机进了。弗雷德说，起初他对ABS持谨慎态度，但他很快就接受了。你知道的，入乡随俗嘛。
They wanted you to follow the system. You call it. I know this collaboration sounds, you know, a little ridiculous, but watching the game, I was pleasantly surprised. It was pretty smooth. It didn't look like a game umpired by a sophisticated missile robot. It just looked like a regular afternoon at the ballpark.
他们希望你遵循这个系统。你就去执行。我知道这种合作听起来有点荒谬，但看了比赛后，我感到惊喜。过程相当顺畅。它看起来不像是一场由复杂的导弹机器人裁判的比赛。它看起来只是球场上的一个普通下午。
And so here's Bernard, right-handed hitter against the lefty groom from the full wind up first pitch. There are no publicly available statistics on the accuracy of the ABS system, but anecdotally, Fred DeJesus says it was pretty damn good. It was very accurate. There were times where you would go, ooo, but again, you did with that machine wanted. There's no dispute here. The ABS is more accurate than a human umpire. Fred says there were some minor glitches when he used it,
所以现在是伯纳德上场，右打者对阵左投手格鲁姆，从完整投球动作开始，投出第一球。目前没有公开统计数据表明ABS系统的准确率有多高，但据弗雷德·德赫苏斯说，它相当不错。它非常准确。有时候你会觉得“噢”，但话说回来，你得按那台机器的要求去做。这里没有什么好争论的。ABS比人类裁判更准确。弗雷德说他在使用时遇到过一些小故障，
but nothing but can't be worked out by the time the system reaches the major leagues. The accuracy thing is huge because there's just so much money on the line. A bad call at the wrong time can ruin a player's career. And sports betting is such a huge industry now. I get why the major leagues want a more accurate system. But a few days after watching the robot umpire in action,
但没有什么是在系统进入大联盟之前不能解决的。准确性至关重要，因为这涉及太多的资金利益。关键时刻的一个误判可能会毁掉一个球员的职业生涯。而且现在的体育博彩是一个如此巨大的产业。我理解为什么大联盟想要一个更准确的系统。但是在观看机器人裁判实地执法几天后，
my doubts started to creep back in. Because accuracy isn't everything. Here's Zach Helfend. I don't think most people watch sports to see the fairest or most accurate outcome. For me, the argument comes down to efficiency and accuracy versus charm and drama and dialogue. The thing is, for more than 100 years, baseball has been played by humans and umpired by other humans and in that process, we've introduced lots of small quirks and inefficiencies. For example, baseball stadiums don't have standard dimensions, so a home run at Fenway Park might just be a long flyball at Dodger Stadium.
我的疑虑开始重新浮现。因为准确性并不代表一切。这是扎克·赫尔芬特。我认为大多数人看比赛并不是为了看到最公平或最准确的结果。对我来说，争论的核心在于效率和准确性与魅力、戏剧性和对话之间的权衡。问题是，在过去100多年里，棒球一直是由人类在打、由人类在裁判的，在这个过程中，我们引入了许多小怪癖和低效之处。例如，棒球场的尺寸并不统一，所以在芬威球场的一记本垒打，在道奇体育场可能只是一记高飞球。
Baseball just has all these unstandardized things. One of them is the application of the strike zone. Again, the textbook strike zone is supposed to be the player's chest to their knees over the plate. But most human umpires don't exactly follow those guidelines. There's lots of pitches that are considered hittable that don't land inside the textbook strike zone. And human umpires usually call those strikes, but the robot umpire they've been slower to pick that up. In 2019 the ABS system was introduced to the Atlantic League,
棒球就是有所有这些不标准的东西。其中之一就是好球区的应用。再次强调，教科书上的好球区本应是球员跨过本垒板时从胸部到膝盖的区域。但大多数人类裁判并不完全遵循这些准则。有许多被认为是可击中的球，并不落在教科书的好球区内。人类裁判通常会将这些球判为好球，但机器人裁判在接受这一点上要慢一些。2019年，ABS系统被引入大西洋联盟，
and it was programmed to call the textbook strike zone, but most fans and players thought the system felt off. The robot was calling a lot of hitable pitches as balls. So when the strike zone is, you know, so coldly unchanging, that sometimes presents some problems. When the strike zone is smaller than what you're used to, games can drag on. Zach Helfen says the league needed to reprogram the ABS to be less accurate in how it called balls and strikes. They expanded it to about,
它被编程为判定教科书式的好球区，但大多数球迷和球员都觉得这个系统感觉不对劲。机器人把许多可击打的球都判成了坏球。所以当好球区变得冷冰冰的一成不变时，有时就会带来一些问题。当好球区比你习惯的要小时，比赛就会被拖得冗长。扎克·赫尔芬特说，联盟需要重新对ABS进行编程，使其在判定好球和坏球时不要那么死板。他们把它扩大到了距离本垒板大约
maybe an inch or an inch and a half off of the plate, counts as a strike, and that better represented what the real strike zone is. You can program the ABS to call a less accurate game, but you can't program it to do all these other things that human umpires just do instinctively. So I'm gonna let you in on a little dirty baseball secret. Umpires are constantly changing the strike zone
一英寸或一英寸半的地方也算作好球，这更好地代表了真实的好球区是什么样的。你可以把ABS编程为判罚得没那么准确的比赛，但你无法把它编程为去完成人类裁判凭借本能所做的所有这些其他事情。所以我得跟你分享一个棒球圈里的小秘密。裁判们一直在根据上下文
based on context. It's raining, let's move this along. Let's get this over with, or one team is up by a lot. Let's just go home. When a pitcher is struggling, there's a demonstrable effect that the umpire zone gets bigger. Sometimes it gets as much as 50% bigger. That's what they call the compassionate umpire effect. So a pitcher is having a really tough time. We're going to help him out. And they don't do this consciously. When you leave it up to the machines to decide balls and strikes, you're ignoring years of training and experience and intuition that every great umpire has.
不断改变好球区。下雨了，我们把节奏加快点吧。赶紧把这场比赛结束掉吧，或者某一方领先很多。我们早点回家吧。当某个投手表现挣扎时，有一个明显的效应，那就是裁判的好球区会变大。有时甚至会扩大50%之多。这就是他们所谓的“同情裁判效应”。所以某个投手正经历一段非常艰难的时期。我们要帮他一把。他们这样做并不是有意的。当你把决定好球和坏球的权力完全交给机器时，你就忽视了每个伟大裁判多年来积累的训练、经验和直觉。
And you're taking away one of those small imperfections that makes baseball kind of romantic. There is a trade-off because you do lose this discussion, you do lose these quirks, these injustices, these twists of fate, where someone blinks or gets dirt in their eye and they make a bad call and that changes everything. I want to see how people react to that. We watch baseball to feel something, to divert ourselves. And sometimes it's nice to feel righteously mad against an umpire or to feel like you got away with something. Okay, but let's talk about righteous anger for a minute because Zach is totally right. Yelling at the umpire is a part of the game.
你也剥夺了那些让棒球带有一点浪漫色彩的小瑕疵。这里存在一种权衡，因为你确实失去了这种讨论，你确实失去了这些怪癖、这些不公、这些命运的捉弄——当某人眨眼或眼睛里进了沙子，从而做出了一个糟糕的判罚，而这改变了一切。我想看看人们对此有何反应。我们观看棒球是为了感受某些东西，为了消遣。有时，能够理直气壮地对裁判发火，或者觉得自己侥幸占了便宜，也是一种美好的体验。好吧，但我们来聊聊这种正义的愤怒，因为扎克完全说得对。冲裁判大吼大叫是比赛的一部分。
Umpires get yelled at by fans and players and mascots pretty much non-stop because unlike other sports, baseball centers the umpire. The umpire is right behind the plate, making judgment calls on every play. And usually the yelling is fun and cathartic and professional umpires can handle it, but it sucks to experience that. Here's Katie Nolan. Imagine going to work knowing you could get a shard of wood directly into your face, or you could get hit by a 100 mile per hour projectile in the face.
裁判们几乎不间断地遭到球迷、球员甚至吉祥物的怒吼，因为与其他运动不同，棒球以裁判为中心。裁判就站在本垒板后面，对每一次击球做出判断。通常这种怒吼很有趣、有宣泄作用，专业的裁判也能应付得来，但经历这种事其实挺糟糕的。这是凯蒂·诺兰。想象一下你去上班，明知自己可能会有一块木屑直接飞进脸里，或者脸部可能会被时速100英里的飞行物击中。
On a on a bad day and on a good, the like ceiling of this job is like you make calls that get people to tell you that you suck at your job and you're the worst and you ruin the game. You know, I've got a video on Instagram right now that's got over 3 million views where the player is saying, Freddie, you're the worst umpire in the league. How did they make you up? Now, he's obviously joking, but this is what the world wants to hear.
在糟糕的日子里，而在状态好的日子里，这份工作的上限就是你做出一些判罚，让人们对你说你这工作做得太烂了、你是最差劲的、你毁了比赛。你知道的，我Instagram上现在有一个视频有超过300万的浏览量，里面有个球员说：“弗雷迪，你是联盟里最烂的裁判。他们是怎么让你升上来的？”现在，他显然是在开玩笑，但这就是世界想听到的。
They want umpires to be ridiculed. And it's not just ridicule. There are stories of umpires receiving death threats or even being physically assaulted by fans. Tonight, a Staten Island parent coach is accused of punching the umpires so hard empires receiving death threats or even being physically assaulted by fans. Tonight a statinile and parent coach is accused of punching the Empire so hard it left him with a broken jaw. CBS2's Lisa Rosner spoke with friends of the Empire in some respect.
他们希望裁判成为被嘲笑的对象。而且不仅仅是嘲笑。有报道称裁判收到死亡威胁，甚至遭到球迷的身体袭击。今晚，一名史坦顿岛的家长兼教练被指控重击裁判，导致……裁判收到死亡威胁，甚至遭到球迷的身体袭击。今晚，一名史坦顿岛的家长兼教练被指控重击裁判，下手之重导致该裁判下巴骨折。CBS2的丽莎·罗斯纳采访了这位裁判的朋友，在某些方面……
People get carried away and it can get scary. I remembered this little league game where I made a really bad third strike call and after the game, a coach was waiting to yell at me in the parking lot. The abuse is actually the primary reason that I stopped umpiring. And it's why my favorite thing about the robot UPS isn't their accuracy. It's their ability to bring down the temperature. Zach Healthin noticed this too when he saw a robot umpiring person. Fans were a lot less likely to get
人们会情绪失控，这可能会变得很吓人。我记得有一次少年棒球联赛，我做出了一个非常糟糕的三振判罚，赛后，一个教练在停车场等着冲我大发雷霆。这种辱骂实际上是我停止担任裁判的主要原因。这也是为什么我对机器人裁判最喜欢的点不在于它们的准确性。而在于它们有能力降温。扎克·赫尔芬特在亲眼看到机器人裁判时也注意到了这一点。当球迷们知道是机器在做判罚时，他们争吵的可能性要小得多。
into arguments when they knew it was a machine making the calls. Some fans who as as fans do and as this part of the pleasure of baseball were heckling the umpire when I was out there. At one point, one of the fans who did know that they were using real vampires this season in that league pointed up at the hardware above home plate and said, you know, it's not the umpire. This is just the strike zone. And the fan was humiliated in a certain way, very humbled. And was like, you know what, is actually calling a pretty good game.
有些球迷——正如球迷常做的那样，这也是棒球乐趣的一部分——当我还在场上时，他们还在冲裁判起哄。有一点，其中一个确实知道那个赛季该联盟正在使用真人裁判的球迷，指了指本垒板上方的那套硬件设备，然后说：“你知道的，这可不是裁判。这只是好球区。”那个球迷在某种程度上感到很尴尬，非常谦卑。并且说：“你知道吗，其实他判得还挺不错的。”
Watching the isotopes Chihuahua's game, I remember this one at bat. So the Isatops third baseman, Taylor Snyder, was at the plate. Count still one and two. Base is juiced. Here's the pitch. Takes a call third strike breaking ball inside corner. That ends the inning.
看着同位素对奇瓦瓦狗队的比赛，我记得有这么一个打席。当时同位素队的三垒手泰勒·斯奈德站在本垒板前。球数依然是一好两坏。满垒。投球来了。面对内角下坠球挥棒落空，被判第三个好球。半局结束。
Isatops do not score. There was two hits, no way. So the batter Snyder, he disagreed with the call. He thought it was inside, and he was clearly furious. He starts to turn towards the ump and it looks like he is ready to yell, but then he didn't. He stopped himself, and he walked back to the dugout. I've never seen that before. And for me, that's a big plus for the idea of Robot Amps.
同位素队没有得分。有两支安打，绝无仅有。所以打者斯奈德不同意这个判罚。他认为那是内角坏球，显然非常愤怒。他开始转身面向裁判，看起来准备大喊大叫，但他最终没有。他克制住了自己，走回了休息区。我以前从未见过这种情况。对我来说，这是机器人裁判概念的一个巨大加分项。
Ultimately, the Robot Umpires are coming. They're going to be used in all AAA games this season. Some games will use a full Robot Umpire system, while others will use the Robot Umpire as an appeal system if the player doesn't like a call. Robot Umpires are probably going to show up in the major leagues in the next couple of years, and I know baseball purists are going to be really mad. I get that. I don't love the general idea of robots muscling in on human jobs, but I think I can live with this new technology, because I'm in favor of anything that makes us see umpires as people.
归根结底，机器人裁判终究会到来。本赛季它们将用于所有3A级别的比赛。有些比赛将使用全套机器人裁判系统，而另一些比赛则会将机器人裁判作为球员对判罚不满时的申诉系统。机器人裁判很可能会在未来几年内出现在大联盟中，我知道棒球纯粹主义者会非常生气。我理解这一点。我并不是很喜欢机器人抢占人类工作的整体构想，但我认为我能接受这项新技术，因为我赞成任何能让我们把裁判看作是有血有肉的人的事物。
Even if that thing is a robot. More sports talk radio with Chris Baroubaik. Chris, I am so sorry, you didn't get to see those minor league baseball games this summer because of COVID. That's terrible. Thank you. I know it's like my favorite thing to do every summer is to go see some minor league baseball.
即使那个事物是一个机器人。更多关于克里斯·巴鲁巴的体育脱口秀电台。克里斯，真的很遗憾，你今年夏天因为新冠没能去现场看那些小联盟的棒球比赛。太糟糕了。谢谢。我知道，去看小联盟棒球赛就像是我每年夏天最喜欢做的事情。
And I used to go see the Brooklyn Cyclones all the time who play down at Cody Island. And they have a roller coaster and left field because the stadium is right next to the amusement park down there. And I remember one time I went and I asked somebody at the stadium, like, well, what happens if they hit a home run into the roller coaster? Like, you know, aren't you worried about that? And he's like, it's never happened. It were not that all right about that. I mean, I just love all these minor league baseball team names. The Brooklyn Cyclone, it's such a great name. I know.
我以前经常去看布鲁克林旋风队的比赛，他们在科尼岛主场打球。他们的左外野就有一个过山车，因为球场紧邻那里的游乐园。我记得有一次我去的时候，问了球场的一个工作人员：“如果他们打出一记本垒打砸进过山车里会怎么样？难道你们不担心那个吗？”他说：“从没发生过。我们对此并不太担心。”我是说，我太喜欢这些小联盟棒球队的队名了。布鲁克林旋风队，这个名字太棒了。我知道。
I kind of love how ridiculous they are. Like we mentioned the Albuquerque Isotopes, which that one's actually a Simpson's joke. Yeah, I was wondering that. So that started as a Simpson's joke and then became real and real. That's right. So the Springfield Isotopes is the team the Simpsons because Homer Simpson works at a
我有点喜欢它们有多荒谬。就像我们提到的阿尔伯克基同位素队，那个其实是个《辛普森一家》里的梗。对，我也在想这个。所以那个最初是《辛普森一家》里的梗，后来变成真的了。没错。所以斯普林菲尔德同位素队是《辛普森一家》里的球队，因为荷马·辛普森在一家
nuclear power plant. And there's an episode where they threaten to move to Albuquerque. And then the real life Albuquerque team was like, ha, ha, ha, that's funny. We're just going to adopt that as our team name. That's awesome. I love that. I love that one too. I beat the ridiculous team name thing.
核电厂工作。有一集里，他们威胁说要搬到阿尔伯克基去。然后现实生活中的阿尔伯克基球队就说：“哈哈，这挺有意思。我们就把这个当成我们的队名吧。”这太棒了。我喜欢这个。我也很喜欢那个。我击败了荒谬队名的梗。
So that's actually a pretty recent thing in minor league baseball. So in the past, there used to be this convention where the minor league team would share a name with the major league team they were affiliated with. So say you have the New York Mets, they have a minor league team. It's called the Binghamton Mets, for example. Right.
所以这其实是小联盟棒球中一个相当最近的现象。在过去，曾经有这样一种惯例：小联盟球队会与他们所附属的大联盟球队共用一个名字。比如说你有纽约大都会队，他们有一支小联盟球队。例如，它被称为宾汉姆顿大都会队。没错。
But in the 21st century, we've seen this big craze of picking more distinct, more ridiculous names. So in 2016, the Binghamton Metz became the Binghamton Rumble ponies, for example. Okay. I think my favorite of this is the Rocket City trash bandas, which are even on the little Vaman. That's a pretty good one. It's so good. I mean, there's so I love so many of them. Like the Hartford Yard Goats is a favorite of mine. The Lehigh Valley Iron Pigs, the Akron Rubber Decks, the Amarillo Saud Poodles. I like the, it's a long list.
但在21世纪，我们看到了这种挑选更具辨识度、更荒谬名字的巨大狂热。例如，在2016年，宾汉姆顿大都会队变成了宾汉姆顿轰鸣小马队。好吧。我想我最喜欢的是火箭城垃圾熊猫队，它们甚至都在小Vaman上了。那真是一个相当不错的名字。太棒了。我是说，有太多我喜欢的了。比如哈特福德山羊队是我的最爱之一。利哈伊谷铁猪队，阿克伦橡胶鸭队，阿马里洛索德犬队。我喜欢……这是一个长长的列表。
Wait, what's a Saud Poodle? It's a Prairie Dog. I think their logo is like a Prairie Dog with a cowboy hat. Oh, that, of course, that makes sense. So why are there so many like this? And why is this kind of a recent phenomenon? So the reason that there's so ridiculous is because you sell a lot more merch this way. So if your team name is the Binghamton Metz, for example, if somebody wants a Metz hat, they're going to get the New York Metz, right?
等等，什么是索德犬？就是草原犬鼠。我想他们的标志就像是一只戴着牛仔帽的草原犬鼠。哦，那当然，这就说得通了。那为什么会有这么多这样的名字？为什么这算是一种近年来的现象呢？所以它们之所以这么荒谬，是因为这样你能卖出更多的周边商品。如果你的球队名字是宾汉姆顿大都会队，举个例子，如果有人想要一顶大都会队的帽子，他们会买纽约大都会队的，对吧？
They're not going to get the second level minor league team. But if your name is the Rumble ponies, you get all this free publicity. Like that was written up in the New York Times when they changed the name. Their whole thing is like, look, you don't have a huge budget for publicity. This is free publicity. Just go with it and, you know, unashamedly take on the ridiculous name. I guess that makes a lot of sense. I mean, but do the old school, you know, minor league baseball fans today like this? Oh no. I mean, baseball fans were way too serious, right? So you can get used to anything, I think, but a lot of them don't like it
他们不会去买第二级别的小联盟球队的帽子。但如果你的名字是轰鸣小马队，你就会获得所有这些免费的宣传。就像他们改名时在《纽约时报》上被报道的那样。他们的整个逻辑就是：听着，你们没有巨额的宣传预算。这就是免费宣传。顺其自然，毫不羞耻地采用这个荒谬的名字吧。我想这很有道理。我是说，但是老派的、你知道的，如今的小联盟棒球迷喜欢这样吗？哦，不。我是说，棒球迷太严肃了，对吧？所以我想你可以习惯任何事情，但他们中的许多人并不喜欢它
because of the random word generator quality to some of these, like Akron Rubberducks feels like you put it into an AI and we're like, come up with a silly name and they did it. Yeah. But the really good ones, they actually aren't random. Like usually there is something interesting and local that the name is rooted in. Oh, so what's what are some good examples of that? Okay, let's go through
因为其中一些名字有一种随机单词生成器的品质，比如阿克伦橡胶鸭队感觉就像是你把它输入到一个AI里，然后我们说：“想个傻气的名字”，他们就做到了。是的。但真正好的名字其实并不是随机的。通常名字都有一些有趣且根植于当地背景的渊源。哦，那有哪些好的例子呢？好吧，让我们来看看
the list. Credit to baseball writer Matt Snyder, who wrote about this last year is very helpful for my research. Hopefully this will make you appreciate these ridiculous minor league baseball team names. Okay. Hartford Yard Goats. There are not goats wandering the yards of Connecticut. That's not what it's a reference to. The stadium where they play is built on an old rail yard, and a yard goat is a vehicle for moving cars around in a rail yard. So it's a reference to the geography of the stadium. Oh, why didn't know that? But the meaning is somewhat obscured by the fact that I think their logo is a goat though, right? Like an actual goat. Yeah, their logo is actually like a goat snapping a baseball bat and half of the sea. Okay.
这个列表。感谢棒球作家马特·斯奈德，他去年写过关于这个的文章，这对我的研究非常有帮助。希望这能让你欣赏这些荒谬的小联盟棒球队名。好了。哈特福德山羊队。康涅狄格州的院子里并没有山羊在游荡。这并不是这个名字的指代。他们打球的球场是建在一个旧铁路调车场上的，而调车场机车（yard goat）是用来在铁路调车场里移动车厢的车辆。所以这是对球场地理位置的一种致敬。哦，我以前不知道这个。但这种含义在某种程度上被掩盖了，因为我觉得他们的标志是一只山羊，对吧？就像一只真正的山羊。对，他们的标志实际上就像一只山羊咬断了一根棒球棒，中间还有个C字。好吧。
Binghamton, Rubble ponies. Binghamton is the carousel capital of the United States, self-described, but that's why it's a reference to like this interesting local quirk. The iron pigs, the I Valley, of course, is in Pennsylvania. That's a state with a huge steel industry, and pig iron is the material that comes out of a blast furnace that you then have to refine to make steel. So it's actually like a reference to local industry. Love it.
宾汉姆顿，轰鸣小马队。宾汉姆顿是美国的旋转木马之都，这是他们自诩的，但这就是为什么它是在致敬这样一个有趣的地方特色。铁猪队，利哈伊谷当然在宾夕法尼亚州。那是一个拥有庞大钢铁工业的州，而生铁（pig iron）是从高炉中出来的材料，你需要对其进行精炼来制造钢铁。所以这实际上是对当地工业的一种致敬。太棒了。
And then my favorite, the El Paso Chihuahua's. So El Paso, Texas is, it's right on the border with Mexico, and the Mexican state of Chihuahua is right across the Rio Grande. So it's a nod to the really significant Mexican influence on the city. And nothing to do with little dogs. I mean, they're logo once again, their logo is a little dog. It is not a map with like El Paso and like the Rio Grande Valley or anything. So I mean, my point is the next time someone says like, oh, that's so random, like, where did they come up with these names? Like, it's not random. Like, there is something
然后是我最喜欢的，埃尔帕索奇瓦瓦狗队。所以德克萨斯州的埃尔帕索，它就在与墨西哥的边境上，而墨西哥的奇瓦瓦州就在格兰德河的对岸。所以这是对该市极其深厚的墨西哥影响力的一种致敬。跟小狗一点关系都没有。我是说，他们的标志又一次是一只小狗。它并不是一张画着埃尔帕索和格兰德河谷之类地图。所以我的意思是，下次当有人说：“天哪，这太随机了，他们是怎么想出这些名字的？”时，这并不是随机的。这些名字都有着某种
local about these names, which I prefer to more serious names that are kind of generic, that don't have anything to do with the place where the team is playing. So say the Grizzlies, the Eagles, you know, or, you know, like in other sports, like the Utah jazz where our franchise moves to a place that once had meaning, but then, you know, the meaning is no longer relevant to the place that they land or the Utah jazz used to be the New Orleans jazz, and then they just moved the team and the name exactly. Exactly. That was so lazy.
本土特色，比起那些千篇一律、与球队所在地毫无关系的更严肃的名字，我更喜欢这种。比如灰熊队、老鹰队，你知道的，或者像其他运动中那样，比如犹他爵士队——我们的特许球队搬到了一个曾经有意义的地方，但后来，你知道的，这种意义与他们落脚的地方不再相关了，或者说犹他爵士队以前是新奥尔良爵士队，然后他们搬迁了球队，名字却完全保留了。没错。太懒惰了。
They couldn't even come up with a different team name because yeah, with all the respect to Utah, not the same rich jazz heritage as a New Orleans. I think we're safe to say that. Yeah, I think we're safe to say that. Well, thank you for this tour of minor league baseball team names. I actually really do appreciate how strange and cool. And now, appreciate how local they are and specifically are. So thanks for that. Of course, thank you, Roman. 99% of us will produce this week by Chris Baroube, edited by Kelly Prime, sound mix by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rial, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colstedt,
他们甚至想不出一个不同的队名，因为，带着对犹他的所有敬意，那里并没有新奥尔良那样深厚的爵士乐文化底蕴。我想我们可以放心地这么说。是的，我想我们可以放心地这么说。好吧，谢谢你带我们游历小联盟棒球队名的世界。我其实真的很欣赏它们是多么奇特和酷炫。现在，我也体会到了它们是多么具有本土特色以及具体指代性。谢谢你。当然，谢谢你，罗曼。本周的“99%隐形”由克里斯·巴鲁巴制作，凯利·普莱姆剪辑，声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔提供，事实核查由格雷姆·海沙负责。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔施泰特
is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Jason Dillion, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of the logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Bobby Lord, Matt Schultz, Rick White,
是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、杰森·迪利安、拉谢马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。“99%隐形”的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。本周特别感谢鲍比·洛德、马特·施尔茨、里克·怀特，
and all the baseball umpires we spoke to for this story. And thank you to Zach Helfen, who was also very, very helpful. You can read his reporting on robot umpires in the New Yorker. 99% of his book is part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now, hit quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
以及我们为这个故事采访的所有棒球裁判。也感谢扎克·赫尔芬特，他也非常非常地帮忙。你可以在《纽约客》上阅读他对机器人裁判的报道。“99%隐形”是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分。总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区，
And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi.org. For our Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to others to share shows I love as well as every past episode of 99pi at 99pi.org. Music you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于美丽的上加州奥克兰市。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，账号是Roman Mars，也可以@节目官方账号99pi.org。我们的Instagram、Reddit和TikTok也是如此。你可以在99pi.org上找到分享我所喜爱的节目的链接，以及99pi过去每一集的节目。音乐……本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。